bevor wir gleich zum wichtigsten
auftritt des tages von karl lauterbach
kommende breaking news hierbei bilden
kaum hat die ampel regierung angefangen
zu regieren schmeißt der erste auch
schon hin nämlich ein staatssekretär im
bundesarbeitsministerium björn böhning
meister der erste verlust der ampel
regierung nach wenigen tagen warum sagte
uns bildpolitik chef jan schäfer warum
hörte erste schon auf bevor sie
überhaupt richtig angefangen haben erste
gute frage also muss man sagen der erste
prominente abgang aus dieser ampel
regierung dieser sechs wochen im amt ist
und unsere kollegin angelika hellemann
die weiß dass björn böhning ein angebot
aus der wirtschaft hat und deswegen
hubertus zeils ministerium verlässt das
kommt für hubertus heil nicht so richtig
günstigen zeitpunkt wir wissen hubertus
heil will in diesem jahr noch den
mindestlohn von 12 euro auf die rampe
schieben will das gesetz durch den
bundestag bringen spielst im herbst soll
es diese zwölf euro minister und gm und
björn böhning wäre da auch ein
entsprechender stelle dann
mitverantwortlich gewesen so der erste
abgang der ampel und lilian chan ist
diejenige eine junge politikerin 42
jahre alt die ihn folgen sollte also
dass die breaking news hierbei bild
bevor dieser tag wieder voll auf corona
fokussiert ist die ampel verliert ihren
ersten starts sehr exklusivmeldung
hierbei gibt und wir schauen gleiche was
karl lauterbach zu sagen hat werden die
regeln die krone regeln in deutschland
wieder verschärft oder haben wir
hoffnung dass sich omikron abschwächt so
wie es jetzt in großbritannien sehen ja
der wichtigste auftritt des tages oben
rechts sehen sie es schon karl
lauterbach unser gesundheitsminister
spricht dort gemeinsam sehen sie gleich
mit dem chirurgen der charité mit
christian drosten und auch mit dem chef
des robert koch instituts mit lothar
wieler die drei werden da gerade mal
vorgestellt vielleicht kann man den ton
schon hören und dann wird der
bundesgesundheitsminister gleich eben
sprechen dazu vor allen dingen ob wir
über diesen omikron berg so langsam
rüber kommen das was in anderen staaten
ja schon passiert ist in großbritannien
beispielsweise in südafrika da fällt die
kurve seit einigen tagen wieder ab dass
also die hoffnung jetzt auch für uns
karl lauterbach
pressekonferenzen zu veranstalten damit
unsere mitgliedschaft die öffentlichkeit
besser informieren kann das als
vorbemerkung und jetzt lautet davon sie
das wort bitte schön ja vielen dank ich
ja die wahrnehmen meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren ich möchte mal bei
ihnen ganz herzlich bedanken dass sie
wieder diese gelegenheit haben hier
neben in ihrem forum vortragen zu dürfen
ich habe neben herrn villa der uns die
aktuellen zahlen und
bewegungen in der pandemie beschreiben
wird heute herrn professor drosten
gebeten uns heute zu ergänzen und zu
verstärken so dass er uns auch einen
ausblick liefern kann er sollte da in
seiner funktion als einzel experte nicht
für den expertenrat hier tauschen wir
uns hat die kinder ab einem jahr
regelmäßig außen ich möchte diese
gelegenheit auch nutzen und mich hier
nochmal öffentlich auch für diese
unterstützung und hilfe zu bedanken
sondern ich auch schon sehr lange
profitiere und sonderlich froh dass
worte mit dabei sind ich wurde kurz
etwas also zum stand der pandemie aus
der sicht des
bundesgesundheitsministeriums berichten
wir kommen jetzt langsam in diese lage
hinein wo wir also omikron als die
großem abstand dominierende
variante sei es zwei varianten bekämpfen
müssen die modellierung des robert koch
instituts hatten einen verlauf wie wir
ihnen jetzt beobachten ungefähr auch
vorher gesagt wir sehen dass also die
kontakt maßnahmen die wir in deutschland
noch am platz haben wirken wir haben wir
ungefähr nur 50 prozent so viele
kontakte im moment wie im vor
pandemischer
zeitalter und diese kontakt begrenzungen
führen dazu dass wir in deutschland
nicht die kurze verdopplung zeit
promikon variante haben die wir in
vielen anderen europäischen ländern
sehen die
top verdopplung ist sogar etwas
gestreckt die sie lag einmal vor wenigen
wochen noch bei ungefähr viereinhalb
tagen durfte jetzt sich auf eine woche
zu bewegen ungefähr 66 100 tagen somit
die maßnahmen die wir ergriffen haben
wirken dazu zählen die 2g regel
beispielsweise im handel die also regeln
die wir geschaffen haben am arbeitsplatz
oder auch also im öffentlichen
personennahverkehr die kontakt
begrenzungen im privaten umfeld und dazu
kommt jetzt zusätzlich die 2g plus
regelungen die wir bei der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz vor einer
woche geschlossen haben worauf läuft das
ganze hinaus deshalb machen wir das
deshalb streben wir überhaupt an dass
sich die verdopplung zeit verlängert
durch die maßnahmen die wir machen der
hintergrund ist der wir wollen aus der
sonst zu erwarten steilen wand der
infektionszahlen wenn möglich einen
hügel machen oder wenn sich das nicht
vermeiden ist dass es an der wand ist
dass die wand nicht so hoch ist das ist
das strategische ziel der
bundesregierung was dahinter steht das
werden uns das gelänge hätten wir
weniger sterbefälle zu beklagen und
weniger schwere verläufe und weniger non
profit fälle weniger komplikationen die
wir nicht wirklich abschätzen können
somit das ziel ist es das unvermeidbare
nehme ich die steigende zahl der omicron
fälle so zu strecken und so zu
reduzieren dass sie mit einer möglichst
geringen zahl von opfern durch diese
welle wegkommen und von dem was wir
bisher sehen zeigen die maßnahmen die
wir ergriffen haben auch die ungefähr zu
erwartende wirkung trotzdem gibt es
keinen grund zu entwarnung die daten die
wir bisher vorliegen haben die zeigen
dass die omikron variante weniger
gefährlich ist als zb die data variante
diese daten sind auf deutschland nicht
eins zu eins übertragen ich habe heute
morgen auch mit den russen noch mal über
eine studie gesprochen die sehr
bedeutsam ist aus kalifornien an der
auch die epidemiologen mal clips von
david school of public health tage
genommen hat wo man sehen kann im
vergleich zu den teils in dieser
methodik guten studie zu sehen dass die
omikron variante nur ungefähr halb so
gefährlich ist was also einweisungen ins
krankenhaus angeht und nur ein viertel
so gefährlich ist was einweisung auf die
intensivstation angeht aber in diesen
studien auch in dieser spezifischen
studie die von der berkeley-universität
gemacht worden muss man beachten
es sind in diesen studien in der regel
weniger ältere menschen die infiziert
waren und ausgewertet worden sind und
wir haben in deutschland die
sondersituation dass wir alle besonders
hohe quote von ungeimpften haben bei der
älteren bevölkerung die darüber hinaus
noch viele risikofaktoren haben das ist
die sondersituation mit der wir in
deutschland umgehen müssen daher sind
die nachrichten die wir bekommen und die
mir auch immer wieder vorgetragen werden
ist das ganze jetzt nicht vorbei mit der
mikrowelle diese nachrichten sind auf
deutschland wahrscheinlich so nicht
übertragbar und ich warne vor dem
gedanken dass wir in deutschland einer
durchseuchung
akzeptieren können die zahl der opfer
die wir dann beklagen müssten ist
ungewiss ist sicherlich zu hoch und es
würde auch nicht dazu führen dass wir
danach eine einen schutz vor weiteren
varianten hätten denn das ist von der
stadt gehabt omikron infektionen nicht
abzuleiten und er ungarn natürlich ich
komme zum schluss meiner kurzen
einführungen also ich glaube dass wir
jetzt in ein schwieriges fahrwasser
kommen wir werden viele menschen
mit infektion versorgen müssen die
krankenhäuser werden an ihre
belastungsgrenze kommen die labore
werden an ihrer belastungsgrenze kommen
wir haben eine neue cola schutzmaßnahmen
ausnahmen verordnung heute im bundesrat
beschlossen dort ist die quarantäne und
die installationszeit auf sieben tage
gekürzt worden diejenigen die aus dem
medizinischen bereich kommen und in
isolation sind müssen einen pcr nachweis
erbringen dass sie nicht mehr ansteckend
sind gemessen an dem ct wert 30 damit
wir diese pcr-test und auch durch werden
können habe ich gestern veranlasst dass
wir diejenigen die aus diesen bereichen
kommen und eine freie testung mit den
pcr benötigen priorisiert werden bei den
labor- und so dass wir sicherstellen
kann dass diejenigen die aus dem
medizinischen bereich kommen und einer
pcr testung benötigen die pcr test um
auch dann bekommen wenn die kapazität
ausgereizt ist oder überlastet sein
durfte schließlich also wir führen die
booster impfkampagne weiter fort ich bin
mit dem booster tempo insgesamt
zufrieden wären es aber noch einmal
beschleunigen wenn es uns gelingt die
also wand oder die bälle so zu
verlangsamen dass wir das poster tempo
nutzen können um möglichst viele zu
ostern die sonst schwer erkannt werden
dann ist unsere strategie aufgegangen
die strategie war ja von anfang an wir
verlangsamen die welle wir strecken die
welle und postern in dieser zeit so
viele menschen wie müll nicht um
diejenigen die dann also sonst infiziert
worden während vor der infektion zu
schützen und wenn sie sich infizieren
dann von schwerer krankheit zu schützen
das ist teil unserer strategie und dafür
ist der impfstoff da ich habe seit
amtsbeginn
55 millionen dosen booster impfstoff für
die bundes für die bundesregierung
erworben wir können hat damit jeder
booster impfung durchführen die in
deutschland sinnvollerweise gemacht
werden könnte herzlichen dank herr
lauterbach
und tag meine damen und herren die
omikron welle sieht und sich weiter auf
und das mit einer dynamik wie wir sie in
dieser pandemie bislang noch nicht
gesehen haben es ist nämlich genau das
eingetroffen was befürchtet wurde im
moment macht omikron bundesweit schon
mehr als 70 prozent aller neuinfektionen
aus nikon dominiert das
infektionsgeschehen in deutschland und
wir gehen davon aus dass ist delta in
den nächsten tagen auch vollständig
verdrängen wird
die fallzahlen sind so hoch wie nie und
sie werden auch weiter steigen in dieser
woche haben die gesundheitsämter
erstmals mehr als 80.000 fälle pro tag
gemeldet innerhalb eines tages und
gestern war diese zahl sogar über 90.000
es gibt im moment geschätzt mindestens
800.000 aktive fälle das ist also knapp
ein prozent der bevölkerung und das
heißt dass einer von 100 menschen in
deutschland jetzt in dem moment mit saas
kopf 2 infiziert ist und das sind ja nur
die fälle von denen wir aus dem
meldesystem kenntnis haben fast jeder
vierte pcr test in der letzten woche war
positiv und
aktuell liegt sieben tage
hospitalisierung incident adjustiert bei
rund 7 und damit ist sie noch
vergleichsweise niedrig für hatten die
höchste etwa bei 15 um weihnachten herum
aber die tendenz steigt wieder das heißt
diese vergleichsweise niedrigen zahlen
sind auch keinen grund zur entwarnung
auch weil zu beginn hauptsächlich
jüngere menschen
infiziert worden sind und wir wissen
dass in den nächsten wochen zunehmend
eben auch ältere menschen betroffen sein
werden der anteil der patienten auf den
intensivstationen geht im moment weiter
zurück auch die zahl der todesfälle in
verbindung mit cupid 19 ist noch nicht
wieder angestiegen das wird sich aber
ändern
selbst eine infektion durch micon
insgesamt milder verlaufen durch die
masse eine infektion müssen wir uns
leider darauf einstellen dass auch die
zahl der hospitalisierungen und der
todesfälle natürlich wieder steigen wird
mit omikron und den massiv steigen falls
hatten treten wir tatsächlich in eine
neue phase der pandemie ein die reinen
fallzahlen werden weniger entscheidend
sein wichtiger ist wie viele menschen
schwer an cupid 19 erkranken und wie
stark das gesundheitssystem dann
belastet sein wird bei der masse an
infektion müssen wir damit rechnen dass
die infektionszahlen über die meldedaten
schlichtweg weniger gut erfasst werden
das hat verschiedene gründe mit
steigender tendenz wird die unter
erfassung größer mehr infizierte ohne
oder nur mit geringen symptomen gehen
gar nicht mehr erst zum testen auch
wegen begrenzter laborkapazitäten wird
nur noch ein teil der infizierten pcs
getestet und daneben auch als fall
gezählt und gemeldet werden außerdem
sind die gesundheitsämter so belastet
dass sie nicht mehr alle kontaktpersonen
identifizieren oder daten zu den fällen
nach recherchieren können das tun sie
jetzt schon kaum noch um das klar zu
sagen auch der diagnosen meldet vollzug
wird natürlich größer da durch das heißt
wir gehen davon aus dass die sieben tage
inzidenz sieben tage aus vitalisierung
incidents und auch die angaben zum
impfstatus am höhepunkt der welle
weniger vollständig sein werden als das
momentan der fall ist das sehen wir auch
teilweise jetzt schon aber
wir werden die situation trotzdem
weiterhin gut abschätzen können erstens
bilden die meldedaten die trends im
infektionsgeschehen natürlich weiterhin
ab zweitens haben wir noch andere zur
balance systeme die die meldedaten
ergänzen zb das intensiv register die
tests zahl erfassung und vor allem aber
die syndrom ische und virologische
surveillance von atemwegsinfektionen
diese sind römische und virologische
surveillance gibt es schon sehr lange
darüber wird zum beispiel erfasst wie
verbreitet atemwegserkrankungen in der
bevölkerung sind welche atemwegs viren
in der bevölkerung zirkulieren wie viele
menschen mit welchen atemwegsinfektionen
ins krankenhaus kommen und behandelt
werden müssen
das ist aktuell besonders wichtig da ja
auch die influenza zunehmend zirkuliert
all diese ergebnisse werden auch schon
lange im coebad 19 wochen bericht
dargestellt sie ergänzen sich
gegenseitig und werden gemeinsam von uns
betrachtet und ausgewertet und diese
gesamtschau macht es in dieser phase der
partie möglich die häufigkeit schwerer
erkrankungen die epidemiologische lage
und auch ihre dynamik weiteren gut
bewerten zu können
nikon hat die lage verändert und kugelt
19 breitet sich so stark in deutschland
aus wie nie aber es ist in unser aller
interesse ansteckungen so gut es geht zu
verhindern die gründe hat minister
lauterbach eben sehr eindrücklich noch
einmal vermittelt wir haben die
werkzeuge und wir können infektionen
vermeiden wenn auch nicht jede infektion
aber jede infektion wie wir verhindern
trägt zur bewältigung der welle 1 bei
und auch dazu das gesundheitssystem zu
entlasten wenn sie einer akuten
atemwegsinfektion haben sollte
schnellstmöglichst abgeklärt werden ob
es sich dabei um kuwait 19 handelt oder
nicht bitte bleiben sie zu hause um eine
übertragung auf weitere person zu
verhindern viele infektionen finden aber
auch zu hause statt wenn in ihrem
haushalt eine kurve 19 test positiv war
könnten sie überlegen ob das tragen
einer maske im eigenen haushalt für sie
eine option ist
denn die maske reduziert eine weitere
übertragung
regelmäßiges lüften muss natürlich
trotzdem stattfinden
und wirklich mein dringender appell wenn
sie noch nicht geimpft sind dann bitte
tun sie es jetzt impfungen verhindern
nicht unbedingt eine ansteckung das ist
wahr aber sie sind der beste schutz vor
einem schweren verlauf die mehrheit der
menschen die wegen co wird 19 auf
intensivstationen kommen die ist
ungeimpft das zeigen nicht nur die daten
zu impfen durchbrüchen aus dem
meldesystem die wir ja wöchentlich
berichten sondern bestätigen auch die
neuen daten aus dem intensiv register
die wir gestern veröffentlicht haben
impfungen helfen also eine überlastung
des gesundheitssystems und alle anderen
gesellschaftlichen systeme vorzubeugen
lassen sie sich impfen und auffrischen
sie schützen sie sich
so schützen wir uns alle auch für
schwere erkrankungen wir sind es auch
den ärzten den ärztinnen und unserem
pflegepersonal einfach schuldig lassen
sie uns gemeinsam auch diese welle in
den griff bekommen
herzlichen dank professor wille
professor thorsten
hallo danke hinten nach unseren regeln
zu sprechen die maske abnehmen aber sie
muss ja
verständlichkeit etwas hört dann geschah
genau ok also es ist glaube ich im
moment eine ganz schwierige zeit zu
kommunizieren also ganz viel wird
missverstanden
es gibt viele gemischte botschaften die
in der öffentlichkeit nicht gut genug
erklärt sind zum beispiel dieses virus
ist tatsächlich milder in seinem verlauf
aber es gibt ja viel zu viele fälle so
dass dann eben diese dieser gewinn über
die milden verläufe wieder ausgelöscht
wird weil es zu viele fälle sind
wir haben positive und negative
botschaften die sie in den beiden
vorträgen hier schon genannt worden
beispielsweise sehr gut dass wir in
deutschland eine längere verdopplung
zeit haben als in anderen ländern wo das
initial alles beschrieben wurde wie
schnell das geht also diese omikron wand
die ist entstanden in ländern in denen
vorher kaum wirklich kontakt maßnahmen
noch in kraft waren volle pubs
beispielsweise die bilder aus england
sind ja bekannt
das sind war natürlich bei uns anders
weil wir ja im herbst schon probleme mit
delta hatten und dann einige
bundesländer der starke maßnahmen
einführen mussten und die diesen
maßnahmen ist dann omikron gekommen und
konnte sich nicht so schnell verbreiten
also diese unterschiedlichkeit die muss
man verstehen
dann haben wir leider eine schlechte
grundvoraussetzung also das war jetzt
eine gute die schlechte ist wir haben
diese im pflücke in deutschland das sind
3 millionen über 60-jährige die gar
nicht geimpft sind und wahrscheinlich
auch noch keine infektion hatten und man
könnte diese zahl erhöhen denn man weiß
inzwischen man braucht für dieses
omikron virus wirklich auch die dritte
impfung um richtig geschützt zu sein und
das sind dann fast neun millionen in
dieser altersgruppe und das ist ja die
gefährdete altersgruppe und wir haben
auch so über 8 millionen bei den
erwachsenen über 18 auf die das zutrifft
und das ist nicht gut
ich glaube die schwierigste doppel
botschaft über die wir vielleicht
sprechen können ist wir werden ja nicht
auf dauer über alle paar monate die
gesamte bevölkerung wieder nach kämpfen
können um damit eine bevölkerungs
immunität oder ein gemeinschafts schutz
wie man das auch immer an ausdrücken
will zu erhalten das geht nicht das
heißt irgendwann muss dieses virus auch
in der bevölkerung infektionen setzen
und das virus selbst muss die immunität
der menschen immer wieder zu sagen wir
mal updaten das ist etwas das ist eine
eine generelle weisheit in der
infektionsepidemiologie also dass da
können wir nichts gegen machen
die frage ist nur können wir das in
deutschland schon tun also in ländern
wie südafrika und so weiter wo sehr
viele infektionen schon gewesen sind
auch zu einem preis da ist dieser
prozess weiter fortgeschritten dieses
erwerben einer immer wieder durch das
virus upgedatet bevölkerungs immunität
wir wissen aber im moment nicht ob wir
uns das in deutschland leisten können
angesichts der imf lücke das ist
tatsächlich unser größtes hindernis
dabei und das kann kaum jemand wirklich
voraussagen es gibt zwar ein paar
klinische studien die sagen wie auch die
dritte und oder die zweite impfung gegen
schweren verlauf schützt und jetzt
könnte man anfangen zu rechnen wie viel
zweiter und dritter haben wir denn wie
viele leute haben wir dann aber da hört
es wirklich auf also an der stelle kann
kein seriöser modellierer noch
irgendetwas voraussagen da sind wir ein
bisschen im blindflug also das ist die
schwierigste doppel botschaft im moment
das virus muss irgendwann laufen aber
vielleicht darf es das jetzt noch nicht
während es in anderen ländern schon dazu
kommt so jetzt wahrscheinlich die zweit
schwierigste doppel botschaft ist es
gibt relativ viele infektionen bei
geimpften und das wird in der
öffentlichkeit zum teil absichtlich und
zum teil aus unkenntnis falsch
dargestellt so als wäre es ja jetzt dann
komplett sinnlos geworden sich überhaupt
noch zu impfen das ist ja auch hier in
beiden vorträgen betont worden nein das
ist es nicht man muss vielleicht bilde
dafür benutzen und dazu wäre es ganz gut
sich mal das virus anzuschauen das würde
ich gerne einmal kurz machen das virus
dass wir jetzt vor uns haben ist eine
immun ist kate variante das heißt dass
das heißt erstmal was wenn wir das
vergleichen mit dem anderen virus das
was wir vorher hatten das waren fitness
varianten also die servieren die sind
einfach besser in ihrer replikation
geworden dadurch dass sie sich besser an
den menschen ohne ansicht der immunität
angepasst haben also zum beispiel an die
atemwege besser angepasst sie müssen
sich das vorstellen so eine fitness
variante das ist wie wenn sie ein auto
haben und dann schauen sie ein anderes
auto an das selbe modell hat aber einen
größeren motor kann schneller fahren
dieses virus hier ist aber jetzt eine
immun ist help variante die immunität in
der bevölkerung ist für so ein virus so
was wie ein unwegsames gelände stellen
sie sich in sandweg vor voller matsch
und
jetzt sehen sie da ist ein auto das
fährt schneller als ein anderes und sie
überlegen woran könnte das liegen und
wenn sie genau hinschauen dann sehen sie
dieses auto das hat eigentlich gar
keinen größeren motor das hat breitere
reifen das kann über diesen match besser
drüberfahren mit einem gleich starken
motor und das ist glaube ich im moment
ein bisschen das omikron virus in
unserer bevölkerung ja wir haben so eine
immunität in allen bevölkerungen das
virus und dass das zeigen
wissenschaftliche daten immer mehr hat
aber von seiner inneren verbreitungs
fähigkeit von seiner ps stärke im motor
eigentlich gar keinen vorteil zu dem was
vorher da war das ist ein auto mit einem
gleich großen motor aber breiteren
reifen für den sandweg und wir sind auf
einem sandweg wenn sie beide autos auf
die autobahn setzen dann sehen sie die
sind weiterhin gleich schnell vielleicht
hat sogar das eine mit den breiteren
reifen kleinen nachteile auf der
autobahn weil es nicht so gut vorwärts
kommen die reifen machen mehr reibung
und dieses beispiel lässt sich
tatsächlich auch übertragen denn das ist
eigentlich was sie sehen wenn sie sich
diese durchbruchs infektionen hier jetzt
anschauen
bei diesen beiden autos also wenn sie
jetzt leute vergleichen die gar nicht
geimpft sind dann sehen sie keinen
großen unterschied das ist eine gute
neuigkeit wir können vielleicht so ein
bisschen davon ausgehen dass dieses
virus deswegen besser kontrollierbar ist
in seiner geschwindigkeit das ist was
wir sehen hier bei uns in deutschland
längere generation längere verdopplung
zeit dieses virus ist in sich gar nicht
stärken wenn wir aber jetzt eben auf
diesem sandweg sind dann sehen wir
dieses virus kommt eigentlich besser
vorwärts obwohl es ihm gleich starken
motor hat ich weiß nicht ob dieses
beispiel nachvollziehbar ist so und
jetzt wäre es eben falsch zu sagen dass
dieser sand wirklich existiert also das
nicht geimpft wurde der sandweg bremst
jedes auto ab die impfung bremst jedes
virus ab das ist ganz entscheiden sich
das klar zu machen und was wir mit der
impfung machen ist wir machen immer mehr
macho auf diesen sandweg drauf bis das
auto irgendwann stecken bleibt dann kann
sich das auto nicht mehr verbreiten wir
haben inzwischen gelernt wir kriegen
keine herdenimmunität bei diesen viren
dh das auto wird sich immer weiter durch
kämpfen aber das wird irgendwann ganz
schön langsam werden und dann sind wir
in endemischen zustand so diesen
endemischen zustand das erwarten wir
schon den werden wir bis ende des jahres
schon entweder erreicht haben oder wir
sind praktisch da das ist glaube ich wo
jetzt im moment so die große spekulation
ist wie wird eigentlich der nächste
winter denn klar ist gegen ostern wird
es wieder wärmer die booster kampagne
läuft zwei effekte die eindeutig dazu
beitragen dass die verbreitung geringer
werden wird von der ganzen problematik
da können wir uns darauf verlassen
jetzt ist nur die frage
reicht der atem bis dahin können wir mit
der booster kampagne schnell genug
nachholen und wie geht es dann im sommer
weiter im sommer wird es so sein wir
werden natürlich wieder ein ganz offenes
gesellschaftliches leben haben können
wird omicron infektionen geben das
wissen wir weil in südafrika auf einer
sehr gut immunisierten bevölkerung dort
im sommer weiter omikron infektionen da
sind das wird bei uns auch so sein
vielleicht wird uns das auch nicht so
stark stören wenn wir weitermachen mit
der immunisierung und dann im nächsten
winter das ist das entscheidende wie
geht es da weiter haben wir dann genug
immunität erreicht und ich glaube in der
alten bevölkerung in deutschland
brauchen wir dann zwei sachen das eine
ist wir müssen wie bei einer influenza
saison auch vorher nochmal die
gefährdeten die älteren die
grunderkrankung mit einer booster
impfung zum herbst versorgen und jetzt
gibt es aber in diesem jahr
wahrscheinlich eine spezialität dieses
omikron virus das ist nebenbei auch noch
ein anderer serotyp davon gehe ich im
moment aus viele virologen gehen im
moment von aus das heißt wir werden
wahrscheinlich auch noch mal bei der
impfung nachsteuern müssen es wird eine
angepasste impfung geben müssen und wir
werden möglicherweise eben dann ab dem
zweiten quartal große teile bevölkerung
vielleicht sogar alle noch einmal mit
einer update impfung gegen omikron
versehen müssen damit wir beide diese
verbreitete impfung haben gegen beide
typen also gegen das neue virus omikron
und gegen alle bis hierher bis dahin
vorhandenen viren die zu einem anderen
ehemaligen serotypen gehört gehören also
diese beiden immunität brauchen wir die
überlappen sich weitgehend bei der
schweren krankheit ist der schutz
gewährleistet aber bei den übertragungs
schutz und im schutz gegen die milde
krankheit brauchen wir beide sorten von
schutz und darauf müssen wir uns
einstellen das müssen wir vorbereitet
und auch hier wieder komme ich nochmal
zum abschluss auf diejenigen zurück die
sich bisher nicht haben impfen lassen
diese personen werden dann
möglicherweise jetzt mit einem omikron
virus in kontakt kommen sich infizieren
fühlt hoffentlich einen milden verlauf
bekommen nur können die sich jetzt
dadurch nicht unbedingt auf dauer darauf
verlassen dass ein delta ähnliches wir
es also ein ursprünglicher
serotyp nicht auch wieder zurückkommt
damit müssen wir rechnen und dass diese
personen dann dagegen wieder im nächsten
winter gar keinen schutz haben das heißt
die haben dann nur diese eine seite die
eine den einen teil der immunität das
ist auch eine sehr schwierige botschaft
in der öffentlichkeit also diese drei
schwierigen botschaften habe ich jetzt
hier angesprochen also das virus muss
irgendwann laufen wir wissen nicht ob
wird uns das schon leisten können das
zweite eben diese wahrnehmung bei den
geimpften gibt es doch ganz schön viele
infektionen ja auf dem matschigen weg
fährt jedes auto irgendwie auch ein
bisschen weiter und das mit den breiten
reifen bisschen schneller hat aber
nichts zu bedeuten auf die motorkraft
und auch nicht das nicht grundsätzlich
auf einem schlamm weg ein auto nummer
langsamer fährt als auf der autobahn
wäre das verkennt der verkehr kann auch
genauso gut dann verkennen dass die
impfungen würden also das ist dann
jedesmal anheimgestellt das ist dann
wirklich die ignoranz
soll die die letzte botschaft eben die
ich da erklärt habe ist dass mit dem
serotyp das ist auch vielleicht für
diejenigen die wissenschaftlich jetzt
nicht so gewohnt sind über solche dinge
nachzudenken noch mal schwieriger zu
verstehen vielleicht hilft es bei der
influenza kennen wir das auch da müssen
wir immer mal die impfung auffrischen so
eine situation haben wir jetzt
herzlichen dank professor drosten dann
kommen wir zu fragen ich habe schon mehr
als 15 fragesteller insofern eigentlich
noch mal in der regel eine frage eine
zusatzfrage und die erste hat heinrich
was den anderen patzen ich würde auch
gleich eine nachfrage noch anmelden
gerade war er wieder trotzten sie haben
jetzt alle drei von diesen doppel
botschaften gesprochen und von der nach
wie vor bestehenden gefahr
von den kontakt produktionen die schon
gibt andererseits beobachten beobachter
in vielen städten das ist die kontakte
weiterhin gibt dass die lokale voll sind
dass sich weiterhin sehr viele menschen
im öffentlichen raum treffen die
mobilität das weiter sehr groß ist es
aus ihrer sicht im aktuellen zustand
verantwortbare oder muss dann noch mehr
geschehen und das zu reduzieren
ich
fange ich vielleicht also zunächst
einmal muss man den erfolg würdigen uns
ist es gelungen die verdopplung zeit der
methode variante zu strecken und wir
haben daher deutlich weniger also fälle
pro tag zu beklagen noch immer zu viele
als andere länder und man muss so eine
strategie ja auch quasi durchhalten
können somit also glaube ich dass wir im
moment maßvoll vorgehen aber wenn
tatsächlich die fallzahlen deutlich
steigen sollten und wir kommen in eine
situation hinein wo wir auch also eine
überlastung beispielsweise der
medizinischen versorgung erwarten muss
nur werden auch sehen dass wir mehr
schwer erkannte haben im moment sinkt
die zahl derjenigen die auf
intensivstation für korrekt behandelt
werden müssen aber wenn das sich ändern
sollte dann muss natürlich mit anderen
maßnahmen gegengesteuert werden aber an
dem punkt sind wir zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt in meiner einschätzung nicht
noch also ist so die omikron welle von
uns so gut beherrscht dass wir wenn wir
die booster impfung kampagnen etwas
beschleunigen könnten dem ganzen also
glaube ich herr werden können
dann als ansonsten will ich nicht
anfangen aber aus jetziger sicht auch
immer an die drei herren reicht 2d oder
zweige plus dann aus also es gibt aus
jeder sicht ist kein anlass schon eine
stufe höher zu schalten
also aus sicht der bundesregierung nur
aus meiner sicht somit ist das im moment
ausreichend was mir mehr sorgen macht
ist das 2d plus noch nicht überall
umgesetzt ist obwohl es geschlossen
haben und was mir auch sorge macht das
also die kontrollen zum teil nicht also
angemessen sind das ist zumindest meine
anekdotisch also an evidenz das ist man
also eindruck den ich bekomme der mir
auch von vielen gemeldet wird wir müssen
stärker werden im vollzug
und dann könnten wir viel erreichen aber
ich glaube dass wir mit durch das
maßnahmenpaket was sie beschlossen haben
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt das richtige
maßnahmenpaket am platz haben klöckner
vom handelsblatt fragt aber explizit
nach auch mit blick auf die mpk halten
sie also weitere maßnahmen nötig dass
man sie gerade beantwortet aber er fragt
oder gar lockerung
also lockerungen kann man zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt ausschließen wir sind mitten
in einer schweren welle mikrowelle und
wir können hier kein risiko eingehen ich
hätte es ganz genauso an wie ist
christian drosten gerade vorgetragen hat
dass wir halt eine große zahl von
ungeimpften älteren menschen haben zum
teil mit erheblichen risiko faktoren zum
teil nach krebserkrankungen wurde also
mit autoimmunerkrankungen
mit metabolischem syndrom und so weiter
und so fort also wir haben keinen anlass
für lockerungen vor die man
danke mit einer frage an herrn
lauterbach und auch an herrn drosten ich
würde sie gerne bitten noch mal was zur
perspektive der kinder zu sagen die ja
gerade
in quarantäne sind und somit das
versprechen sozusagen kitas und schulen
bleiben offen ja nicht so ganz gehalten
werden kann wenn dann keiner hin gehen
darf sehen sie vor dem hintergrund der
omicron variante sozusagen also wie
bewerten sie die omikron variante mit
blick auf kinder und sind da vielleicht
dann doch auch perspektivisch noch
weitere lockerungen sachen quarantäne
möglich ich möchte kurz dazufügen die
frage von frau prognose von ansa
auch ein professor wieder ist omikron
die variante für kinder aggressiver sind
die verläufe mit
dieser mutation schwerer wie viele
kinder sind aktuell auf den endstationen
und erwarten sie eine zunahme der zahl
bis zu sammeln beantworten
vielleicht fange ich an also die
datenlage zu kindern ist sehr schwierig
auszuwerten
zuerst gab es ja sehr beunruhigend daten
das also kinder schwerer erkranken
würden
es gab auch eine gewisse plausibilität
dafür ich lese die daten also
mittlerweile anders dass es so sagen
könnte dass kinder nicht schwere
erkrankung möglicherweise sogar leichter
erkranken und ich lese die daten im
moment auch so das ist nicht so ist dass
die omikron variante mehr viruslast auf
was somit könnte es sogar sein dass
kinder also in den schulen sich nicht so
stark infizieren wie mit stadtgarten
varianten das aber noch unklar ich weiß
ausdrücklich darauf hin dass das unklar
ist das ist meine lesart der situation
dass wir auf jeden fall sehen das mikro
sehr gut reagiert auf schutzmaßnahmen
wie zum beispiel masken basteln spielen
bei nikon variante aus verschiedenen
gründen eine große rolle das hat auch
damit zu tun dass die sogenannte
generation styles sehr kurz ist das
heißt die zeit in der jemand also
ansteckend wirkt und ansteckend ist und
werden es auch stattfindet dann also
wirken also maßnahmen kontakt
beschränkungen oder auch meinetwegen
masken tragen die würden dann sehr stark
das sind ja die maßnahmen in den
klassenräumen oft eine große rolle
spielen somit könnte es sein das wissen
wir aber zum jetzigen zeitpunkt nicht
genau was mit diesen klassischen
methoden maske tragen lüften zwischen
den schulstunden stoßlüften steht
zwischen den schulstunden und also
also isolation der infizierten kinder
und vielleicht auch einer quarantäne die
sich begrenzt auf wenige kinder oder
tägliches testen sogar was du durch die
schulen
lassen durch die schule welle
durchkommen ohne dass wir zuviel
schulausfall haben
schulschließungen dafür sehe ich zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt keinen namen hast
ja ich kann das nur ergänzen in teilen
also tatsächlich ist die datenlage über
die krankheit schwerer bei kindern noch
nicht eindeutig es gibt eine aktuelle
arbeit aus den usa die gerade kinder
unter fünf jahren betrachtet und nach
dieser studie sieht man milde verläufe
ich werde aber natürlich nur von den
akuten
krankheitsfällen wir wissen ja nicht
genau wie langzeitfolgen von kuwait
auftreten gibt zum beispiel eine us
amerikanische studie glaubens letzte
oder vorletzte woche die das untersucht
hat wo man dann doch bestimmte risiken
für folgekrankheiten erkannt hat dass da
möchte ich einfach dass das nie
vergessen wird dass es eben auch dieses
longo wie der post gibt vor allem in
long beach
diskussionen die die wir noch nicht
richtig fassen können aber ich möchte
immer darauf hinweisen dass wir auch das
im kopf haben müssen wenn wir schwitzen
und warum wir schützen sollen kinder und
auch noch nummer ergänzen wichtig ist
wirklich das schlichtweg die maßnahmen
halt in den schulen auch angewendet wird
minister laut darauf sagt ist gerade der
vollzug diese anekdoten hören wir ja
alle dass eben bestimmte regeln nicht
vollzogen und kontrolliert werden und
das erschwert natürlich die kontrolle
des virus und den schulen es gibt ganz
klare empfehlungen es gibt sogar s3
leitlinien für schulen und die müssen
eben dann auch entsprechend umgesetzt
werden und dann kann man das auch im
griff haben
dann die nächste frage stelle rinke ja
danke schön herr
lauterbach sie haben eben auf die
priorisierung bei der pcr tests
hingewiesen jetzt gibt es ja kritik dass
deutschland im vergleich
internationalen vergleich begrenzte
laborkapazitäten auch pcr kapazitäten
hat das verhält sich ganz gerne gefragt
ob sie da ein manko sehen bei dafür wie
deutschland aufgestellt ist und müsste
man zb die kapazitäten deutlich weiter
ausweiten über die 2,6 millionen tests
pro woche hinaus die im moment zur
verfügung stehen
im vergleich zu vielen anderen
europäischen ländern ist die kapazität
für pcr untersuchen in deutschland eher
hoch wir haben hier aus meiner sicht
keinen lange wir sind jetzt natürlich in
einer situation wo wir an die volllast
des systems herantreten soweit ich
informiert bin ist die pcr also
nutzung in
england mittlerweile eingestellt worden
so dass das dort also die bestätigende
also untersuchungen mit einer bisher
untersuchung gar nicht mehr durchgeführt
wird an dem punkt sind wir keineswegs es
wäre immer besser wenn man mehr pcr
kapazität hätte aber die also welle
werden wir beherrschen können ich habe
in auftrag gegeben das die also antigen
tests die verfügbar sind in bezug auf
ihre
sensitivität für die omikron variante
untersucht werden wir wissen aus
stadtgarten
analysen die auch durch das paul ehrlich
institut bereits also veröffentlicht
worden sind und dass 80 prozent der anti
gen tests die auf dem markt sind die wir
empfehlen zertifizierte test
schätzungsweise auf der omicron
funktionierende wissen auf das wie an
die gentests insbesondere in späteren
stadien der omicron infektion besonders
gut wirken in frühen phasen wirken sie
nicht ganz so gut was ich daten auch
sehr viel videomaterial in der intakten
zelle befindet wo der test natürlich
dann nicht so gut funktionieren kann
also der bei der sogenannten frei
testung wird und die anti gen test sehr
gut wir haben auch bereiche wo wir noch
test einsparen können ich glaube selbst
dass man also bei der varianten
verteilung die wird jetzt in deutschland
haben den so genannten varianten pcr
durchaus kritisch sehen kann ob er noch
als notwendiges zum jetzigen zeiten
somit werden wir darüber reden wo wir
also einsparen können aber für diesen
besonders bedeutsamen bereich der frei
testung von medizinischen
pflegekräften ersten ersten also auf
andere medizinischen personal mit dem
platz pcr mit durch den grenzwert was
wir heute in der krone schutzmaßnahmen
ausnahmeverordnung geregelt haben dafür
haben wir genug pcs und dafür habe ich
die priorisierung gestern abend
vorbereitet durch eine kurze frage
stellen weil sie das gerade erwähnt
haben würde ich die waren natürlich alle
bieler aufstellen wenn sie den verzicht
auf die
sequenzierung und die pca testung auf
virusvarianten auch als sinnvoll an im
moment
also es gibt ja den nationalen test
strategien gibt ja seit annähernd zwei
jahren kontinuierlich angepasst das sind
ja strategische ziele die man haben muss
also man darf nicht glauben nur wenn man
immer mehr irgendetwas tut dass dadurch
die situationsanalyse besser wird wenn
man ganz viele verschiedene
möglichkeiten die schwere der pandemie
zu messen ich habe eben einige
aufgelistet und es gibt eine natürliche
kapazitätsgrenze und diese grenze wenn
die erreicht wird dann fokussiert man
und die fachleute wissen das auch und es
gibt entsprechende empfehlungen des
hauses und ja wenn man zum beispiel eine
hundertprozentige omikron welle hat also
wenn wirklich omikron geld komplett dann
verdrängt haben wird dann wird es in
diesem moment natürlich nicht mehr so
wichtig sein so viele sequenzierung
durch sven das heißt dass alles was sie
beschreiben ist ja für fachleute ein
tägliches handwerk dass sie alle
beherrschen und wir passen sogar die
nationale strategie kontinuierlich an
also das heißt diese ganzen art und
weise wie wir testen werden das wird
sich ändern wir werden ja auch
irgendwann wenn wir in der situation
sind von der christian drosten eben
sprach wenn das mal endemisch ist dann
wenn wir auch natürlich deutlich weniger
testen weil wir dann einfach gar nicht
mehr so einen überblick haben müssen
wenn wir nicht diese akuten wellen haben
also das test verhalten der umgang mit
dem ganzen panini ändert sich
kontinuierlich das auch dass das
schwierige natürlich zu kommunizieren
aber sie können glauben was die
fachleute im wissen was dann zu tun ist
ich wollte ihm zu impfpflicht kommen
hier wie da können sie mal aus ihrer
sicht beschreiben was die vorteile einer
impfpflicht wehren und hosten man sie
auch die impflücken
angesprochen hatten im november gesagt
das ideal ziel müsse eine dreifach
komplett durch geimpfte bevölkerung
seien wäre demnach eine impfpflicht
ideal
also zunächst mal das wichtige ist mir
was wirklich verstanden werden muss je
mehr menschen geimpft sind und die mehr
dann auch drei mal geimpft sind desto
besser kommen wir unser land das kommt
durch diese pandemie und desto mehr
schwerer krankheiten verhindern wir und
desto mehr todesfälle verhindern das
heißt also das ziel muss sein eine
möglichst hohe impfquoten jetzt ist
dieser aspekt
schafft man das mit dem was wir momentan
tun wenn man die untersuchung von cosmo
anschaut die ja gott sei dank seit märz
2020 immer wieder fragen stellen und
immer wieder einen einblick gibt auch
andere untersuchen aber die finde ich
jetzt ganz schön weil sie eben schon so
lange läuft auch sehr wichtig ist dann
merkt man da steht drin dass die
menschen die sich jetzt nicht haben
impfen lassen dass viele von denen auch
sich nicht mehr impfen lassen wollen
also ich sage jetzt mal so die motiviert
man wahrscheinlich nicht mehr wir können
noch einige motivieren das heißt wir
müssen das wir müssen das angebot weiter
also die barrieren senken müssen alles
tun also die die strategie die gefahr
wird mit boostern ist genau richtig wir
müssen alles tun so viel wie möglich
anbieten
barrierenfreien wieso aber
offensichtlich reicht dass er nicht das
heißt also die these ist dann mit einer
impfpflicht erreichen wir mehr und das
was wenn das stimmt diese these ich
persönlich denke dass das stimmt dass
wir damit mehr erreichen würden dann ist
der vorteil wir würden mehr impfen dann
ist der vorteil ganz einfach wir würden
mit mir impfungen mehr krankheiten
verhindert wir würden auch in gewissem
maße die transmission reduzieren man hat
schon einen schutz der infektion der
schutz vor inflation ist nicht
überragend aber es ist immer noch einer
da und ich möchte auch noch mal darauf
hinweisen abgesehen von den ganzen für
meine begriffe der technokratischen
betrachtungen dass wir das
gesundheitssystem mit last und
krankenhäuser entlassen in den lift und
wir hätten einfach mehr leben und wir
wir haben einfach mehr gesunde menschen
und ich möchte den letzten aspekt noch
machen wenn wir mehr impfen dann haben
wir auch weniger longkou wiegt das
möchte ich immer wieder sagen wir wissen
noch nicht wie groß die krankheitslast
damit sein wird aber wir wissen dass es
wirklich sehr viele menschen sein werden
die darunter leiden und auch longo wird
können wir damit reduziert es gibt doch
daten das pimps diese seltene
komplikation bei kindern das auch da
eine reduktion durch impfungen ist als
insofern ist das ziel möglichst viel zu
impfen wenn es mit einer impfpflicht
erreicht wird ist das der richtige weg
ja ich glaube da muss ich gar nicht viel
zu fügen also für mich ist dieses thema
in pflicht und politisches thema ich
kann als biologe sagen dass wir
möglichst die diese lücke schließen
müssen im moment kann man natürlich
einfach nur mehr kraft auf das laufende
programm geben über dem sommer wird man
sich eben überlegen müssen wie man den
herbst vorbereitet den winter
vorbereitet dass man bis dahin
diese impfquote weiter erhöht die
impflücken weiter schließt dass
möglichst viele leute das verstehen oder
ist einfach machen und da ist sicherlich
in pflicht eine der möglichkeiten ist
eine andere möglichkeit ist immer
motivation und ansprache zu arbeiten
aber da scheinen die aussichten begrenzt
zu sein auch die medien könnten helfen
muss man hier vielleicht auch mal sagen
diese motivation und ansprache zu
verbessern einige wenige medien haben ja
über lange zeit in der vergangenheit
immer die darstellung auch propagiert
das ganze ist eigentlich harmlos und die
maßnahmen der politik das ist ja alles
total übertrieben auch das hat natürlich
dazu beigetragen dass viele leute dann
so in
einverständnis konflikt auch gekommen
sind also dass viele leute gedacht na
wenn das so ist das ist alles total
harmlos und andererseits sehe ich da
wird über eben pflicht geredet dann
komme ich in einen inneren verständnis
konflikt und
die folgen sehen wir glaube ich derzeit
in der gesellschaft und ich glaube es
wäre gut wenn die medien helfen würden
auch an dieser stelle wieder
korrekte informationen zu liefern
der bundestagsabgeordnete lauterbach ist
eine impfpflicht vor der sich aber der
bundesgesundheitsminister drückt und
keine eigenen vorschlag einbringen will
wo ist ihre führungsstärke lauterbach
provokante frage also erstmal der
bundesgesundheitsminister drückt sich
vor nichts und ist dafür auch
wahrscheinlich nicht bekannt aber was
ich also richtig finde ist dass ich mich
als
bundesgesundheitsminister
nicht offiziell zu dieser frage
ausgebrochen werden eben pflicht oder
nicht weil ich muss allen abgeordneten
mit meinem haus zu erwarten die anträge
vorbereitet anträge die
impfpflicht ablehnen eine anträge die
anleinpflicht ab 18 wurden anträge die
an endlich ab 50 waren muss ja alle
unterstützen und das natürlich nicht
wenn ich gleichzeitig als minister also
alles einmal ans meinung habe das ist
also dann können wir uns auch das ganze
manöver von gruppen anträgen sparen wenn
die abgeordneten quasi also hier
von der regierung dann doch bevormundet
werden wie es gehen soll das wäre dann
der gefahr dann würden wir ja doch dann
also das ganze manöver dass man also
dass etliche anträge aus dem parlament
entscheiden dass sie das ganze manöver
könnten wir uns sparen wenn wir als
bundesregierung war sie eigene anträge
machen würde aber trotzdem also als
abgeordneter meine position noch einmal
ganz klar sagen ich bin ohne wenn und
aber für eine impfpflicht ich bin für
eine impfpflicht ab 18 ich glaube dass
wir sonst also im herbst wieder vor
einer situation stehen die wir nicht
wollen ich glaube nicht dass die omikron
rand die letzte variante sein wird das
halte ich für fast ausgeschlossen
wir sehen jetzt schon wieder genetische
veränderungen in der delta variante mit
der bis vor kurzem gerungen haben die
vom serotyp er sehr weit von der oregon
variante entferntes christian rosner das
gerade sehr präzise dargestellt somit
also
würden wir im herbst wenn also wir keine
impfpflicht umsätzen
vorsorgesituation stehen wir hatten dann
wieder eine noch immer
bestehende große gruppe von gefährdeten
menschen die ungeimpft sind und einige
haben sogar ihren impfschutz den sie
hatten verloren weil eine neue variante
geist das wäre das wahrscheinlich
ergebnis und das also will ich als
abgeordneter uns mit
das will ich uns einfach ersparen dass
wir dann erneut vor der frage stehen
brauchen wir einen lock down wie kommen
wir können wir dich gut können wir den
schulbeginn wagen das muss ja nicht
unbedingt eine variante sein die so
harmlos verläuft wie wir uns das
wünschen ich hatte mich auch die omikron
variante nicht verharmlosen das noch mal
klar zu sagen das habe ich ja
interessant abzuleiten für die
ungeimpften ist selbst diese variante
nicht harmlos wir können aber eine
variante bekommen diese ansteckendes und
sehr viel gefährlicher als es kann
niemand ausschließen und was wir wissen
ist diejenigen die grundimmunisierung
sind und grund immunisiert bedeutet das
stimmig christian posten zu dreifach
geimpft sind die sind von schweren
verlauf und tod
soweit wir sehen können für alle uns
bekannten
bestehenden varianten geschützt das
heißt wir werden dann in einer situation
wo wir dann kaum mehr menschen hätten
die so schwer erkranken würden und dass
sie schwer erkranken oder versterben und
diesen könnten wir dann möglicherweise
mit den uns zur verfügung stehenden
medikamenten gut versorgen dann hätten
wir weniger schwere fälle und die
könnten sie auch noch medikamentös
versorgen ich glaube dass wir das machen
sollten ich glaube dass wir als
gesellschaft für die ungeimpften die
jetzt im risiko stehen sehr viel tun wir
geben viel auf selbst unsere kinder
gehen fiel auf wir geben wir bringen
enorme mittel auf um die zu schützen
insbesondere die zu schützen den noch
ungeimpft sind wir können im gegenzug
aus meiner sicht von diesen menschen in
zukunft auch die impfung verlangen weil
die sendung ist fast nebenwirkungsfrei
und schützt vor schwerer krankheit so
dass wir unser normales
gesellschaftliches leben wieder
aufnehmen können das ist meine
persönliche einschätzung und die frage
ja das sagte bundesgesundheitsminister
karl lauterbach und die drei sind sich
einig lothar wieler christian drosten
und auch der bundesgesundheitsminister
dass wir mit mikro neben noch nicht über
den berg sind sie wollen also weiter an
den maßnahmen festhalten sehen aber bis
ende des jahres dann eine immunität
beziehungsweise hoffen dass die
immunität erreicht ist und dass sich die
lage dann entspannt das war es für den
moment hierbei bild live an diesem
freitag wird nur zu ein bisschen
optimistisch ein bisschen positivere
corona nachrichten ganz zum ende dieser
woche noch gewünscht die gab es noch
nicht von karl lauterbach die briten
über den berg sind sind wir leider sagen
die drei noch nicht trotzdem ein schönes
wochenende gehen das war es für den
moment von bild lang ist